so I mention it right and they go we got
to go to the doctor I went over there
today and my my my doctor Dr kawashiri
can I say his name you can't well you
just did yeah you did he's a great guy
yeah he's a good guy yeah he's one of
the best don't bleep it okay I'll I'll
make louder yeah maybe they'll that
maybe there's some promotion there for
him oh good yeah maybe does he
specialize in
Asians I mean I mean with a last name
like that you know what's weird he could
it he could because I go to my doctor Dr
oh
hulahan
he specializes in therosis of the
liver yeah maybe I should switch it up
maybe I should get a black doctor or
something it just it seems could you be
a little more woke and maybe go to
another race for your
doctoring all right so he goes so he
goes uh I tell him the problem he goes
okay so um bbby uh bend over and I you
know I for I've never been like one to
go are you sure M about bending over
like I'm like you know me I'm I I I jump
in there's a party I'll jump in so I
bend over take my pants off obviously
right and what did you do
first oh that's interesting that's
interesting oh yeah that's interesting I
think I [__] I thought that was going
to get a laugh I thought it was a
ridiculous question you're going to
break it he just goes oh that's
interesting no no that was interesting
you know because you
a normal person would have take taken
the pants off first and then B over but
what you just said was I did bend over
first and then took my pants off of
course you did that's so [__]
weird oh my go I bent over and they
there was that that that moment where
the doctor goes you know what I mean oh
my God what are you doing ah right and I
go I know how it works this is the way I
do it right so I bend over then I I like
it you made it weird
back yeah yeah I reversed it you took
control of the weirdness I like it now
he's weirded out right and he goes what
are you waiting for big
boy so he does you know he you first you
hear a a noise like something's coming
out of a tube okay right so right so he
has to put the Lube on and whatnot he
has the glove on and then he doesn't um
you know he Pearl Harbors it I I know
he's
Keri but instead of
was fly around the island he
went yeah but he told you he was doing
it it wasn't a sneak attack it was a sne
it now he said hey sit down next to me
because I won a
321 don't you want a 321 when it comes
to your [__] someone yelling that out
three I'd rather rip the Band-Aid off no
not me don't you want that well they're
supposed to I will be entering your
[__] in three yes yeah two so I could
like clinch or whatever I my body does
they usually say going to be a little
cold because of the cold he said nothing
you're going to little pressure feel a
little pressure is a is a classic
medical and he I bent over pull the
pants out and then Bai is what
IAI and just any c he goes it's just my
um index finger right yeah I go no that
was your thumb bro he thumbed it you're
positive I I I I I I don't have reverse
you know mean sight reverse sight I mean
I don't have the there's no I don't know
if there's cameras in the room but I
think he [__] thumbed
in it hurt or I might have a tight
[__] or he has short
fingers I never thought
of I never thought of the third [__]
option yeah yeah he could have got
little hands maybe he's got little hand
you probably gave him a complex he came
home came home all Moody and his
girlfriend's like what's the matter I
don't want to talk about it what's the
matter
it happened again what
happened oh I put my index finger in
somebody's [__] and they were
convinced it with my
thumb you don't understand it's a man
thing okay yeah yeah yeah maybe I going
have [__] his day up but good news is
that he I don't know how he checks but
he goes no blood well you're not going
to know for a while sweetheart no but he
goes that's a big thing he goes if he
goes there's no traces of blood in the
entrance of the Ari so he's like you
know he said that you know I cuz I'm
going to Hawaii Friday so I don't I want
to I don't want to be like do I have
colon cancer or yeah but you can't
you're going to need a colonoscopy
you're almost
50 did you do one yeah it's the easiest
thing ever yeah like okay this is going
to smell like peppermint and then 5
seconds later it's like all right your
ass is great no problem that's literally
what it feels like yeah but she was
saying what sucks is the day the day
before the stuff you have to drink is a
little bit gross but when when you
weighting that versus ding of ass cancer
it's just like all right yeah I'll
definitely I'll choose this yeah yeah
I'm going to tell you how I discovered
you I you know I I do owe my whole
career to you I was I was struggling
until Lobby discovered oh no not
discover you in terms of like you did it
on your own obviously but no in terms of
I my awareness of you oh can I tell you
that story I remember it was a big day
in my career Bobby Lee is finally aware
of
me am I on Bobby Lee's radar see this is
what he's going to this is when things
start to happen I'm not going to allow
this to reversal I'm not yeah I'm not
going to allow this to happen reveral
yeah yeah I'm just going to plug away
you know what I mean listen you can talk
to him all you want I can hear
it flexiglass it's not soundproof so
your ago years ago um I had no idea who
you were and um I was in a car with
Steve Burn and Ken Jung and we're um
driving from San Francisco to LA because
we had to do gigs together at that time
because we couldn't draw on our own and
so he sturn loved
Oasis we kept playing Oasis over and
over again like he still does I know
right it's like give it a rest right
they have three songs good songs
Champagne Supernova wonder wall and some
other one okay don't look back in that
that's it great songs but that's it so
and I we go what do we listen to and he
and he goes well I have a friend from
New York you know he you're you we have
I have this comedy CD and we're like we
just [__] listen no [__] comedy right
now bro what the [__] you know mean
we're [__] eight hours in the [__]
the [__] some open micers [__] seat
or whatever right he puts it in no it
was very funny but there was one bit
about you in the Subway and then you saw
some guy pick a girl up and then you're
high pitch voice you I mean oh yeah he
was grabbing by the backing me or the
bit right and we laugh so hard and
that's when you know what I mean when I
oh Bill bur Bill bur Bill bur and then
um now you're one of the greatest
comics on the on the planet how does
that
feel what what's that character you just
I don't even take it know it's just I'm
plugging away I'm doing all right doing
all right well I it's great because of
the fact that it's like you know here's
here's the deal the honest truth is
this I just love that whole body L okay
here's here's the deal here let's get
real let's get real so um you know I'm
almost 50 and I feel like um things are
kind of slowly happening for me as well
right it's just nice to see like what
you talking about you've been on [__]
television for like almost 30 years what
are you talking about Mad TV oh my God
and everything else okay first of all
mad tv was like doing community theater
that's how much we got paid I'm not I'm
just I'm just I'm just telling you oh
did you get [__] over in Show
Business did you think there was a big
pot of gold and then somebody else took
it from you yeah that's what happens but
you were still on TV you still walk down
the street and people like oh my God
it's Bobby Lee from Mad TV okay fine
fine you're right and I'm Greatful okay
but I'm just saying that empathy that I
have for you right now is just awesome
how much of your day is trying to pick
this
up and keep it yeah I know I know see
the thing about him though I have to
stand okay yeah yeah go ahead thing
about him is that I feel like I'm
getting cross-examined yeah thing about
him is is that he he has a ways he's one
of those guys like Whitney is like that
too where she sees you know me behaving
in a certain way to gon her some sort of
sympath sympathy or you know I I'm doing
something psychological right so I can
get something out of some and and he
sees through it where other people they
fall into it and they go oh no you know
me and they you know I mean I I've just
been around a lot of dirt bags so I
I yeah yeah I've been taking advantage
of a couple of times I know when it's
happening yeah but you could see through
that but I'm just saying that um let's
go back to what I was doing originally
which is um you're doing well and
congratulations that's all I wanted to
[__] say thank you I appreciate that
I appre appreciate that I mean you're
killing it I love the Mandalorian right
he all of a sudden I didn't even know
you were on it and you have when you're
watching something you love right and
then you see a guy that you know up
there killing it you go oh my God it's
[__] crazy right and then like and
then he's in the the the the the appat
movie mhh and but just you know he's
killing it that's all I wanted to say I
know you don't like compliment I caught
up to you I know you don't like
compliments
why what why don't Comics why do Comics
not like compliments I know I think some
of them do look I I I
respect you know other Comics liking
what I do I do enjoy that [__] but I
don't want to sit here and and just like
listen to
that you're giving him the worst
experience I just want to like hang out
and make whoever's watching this laugh
you don't have to go James
lipon cuz when when a girl sees my penis
for the first time I get this sound oh
oh yeah or um oh oh wow like a like
that's it wow you know not like a baby
you know I've heard Comics talk about
like you know uh girls making baby
sounds like a no it's more
like like a question I actually think
it's bigger than than assumed well
that's the thing you key to life is low
expectations so I think he
like no he's very smart if you have a
smaller siiz dick you say it's the
smallest thing in the world and then
when girls imagine IM it almost not
there then they see it they're like wait
a minute that's not the smallest thing I
know what you're up to you this is what
you do this is your sh you're the
smartest guy in the room and you act
like the dumbest guy in the room I know
it's you I do this I I know you before
though but I used to do this as as a
comedian right I would like meet a girl
like this is before I was on TV and I
know that I had a 15-minute set that
destroyed but I would meet a girl and I
go I'm all right I'm average right and
then you bring them in the room right
and then you destroy right and then you
know what I mean yeah baby that's how
started doing it with your dick you
started doing the same thing with your
dick as you did with the com yeah yeah I
always lowball things dude I you know in
fact when I go into any job I always
think the worst is going to happen so
you prepare yourself for disaster and
then if it doesn't happen it's a success
it's a success yeah because if it's if I
go in there with I've done this before
where I've like I was in that movie The
Dictator yes and I would go I'm going to
kill it this is my time to shine and and
then there was like a couple of scenes
where it was like not working yeah you
know and like people are like you know
how they they Mumble at V video Village
uh so you do its take and and then all
the producers and directors they get in
a huddle and they go no that wasn't it
that was terrible you know what I mean
and they look it back at it and why
don't we hire that guy and whatever they
they say I hate that right like a Tom
Cruz blow up or do you ever like really
go for it dude what do you think of his
blow up I respected
he did it for
you literally like nobody has a blow up
and only positive [__] H like but let me
just say we got to save the turtle like
right like who get gets angry and
doesn't curse and just as positive
things if he dropped like an end bomb in
the middle of it I'd be like oh okay
this guy really
fu yeah yeah he just was the best guy
yeah like we got to save people's lives
in their college education theory that I
think that was a PR move yes but but
that's just because I think that you
know his stocks have dropped since the
whole David miscavage thing and he keeps
doing these big action movies but he's
really kind of out of the Oscar
Contender kind of category so I think I
think that was his attempt to kind of uh
Galvanize support in the industry and
like make him look like a good guy like
he can because he worked on me exactly
because you really care about Corona I'm
immune so I'm like you [__]
[__] but he he he used his power and
that's when you know he has power
because if I would have done it this is
what this is what it would happen this
is what it would happen right hey guys
I'm going to tell you right now and then
somebody would go [__] you and it's the
[__]
gopher right or the guy holding the boom
[__] you sit down [__] right and I'd
be like Oh I'm sorry right whereas they
let Tom go go and I'm going to say this
that last [__] mission imposs movie
he did bomb dude one of the best action
movies I've ever [__] he's a beast he's
a beast he's a weirdo but he's a beast
though yeah that's the thing like if he
was funny he'd probably be one of us
like he's weird enough to be one of us
he's just not funny no but you know I
have to admit he was in Tropic Thunder
he thought he was really acting no but
he was funny I think he was trying to be
funny I thought he was was they were
like seriously be this we need you to be
that guy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he is
a weirdo but you know what dude it just
just shows his power yeah you know what
I mean you could probably do that on
your new Netflix show damn right I could
yeah is it a show or a special what is
it I mean it's an hour special that we
broke up in four episodes so it's like
15 minutes each right and they're it's
what you were doing on Instagram
Instagram literally yeah and then they
they put it on Netflix yeah we just
filmed like longer versions of it yeah I
love how the last time you were here we
were talking so much [__] about Netflix
bro I had to do it but now I know know
how it works that's how it works right
like how do you get laid by like telling
a girl she's amazing or being like Oh I
got another girl yeah what's that wait
what's that book that people used to
guys the [__] how do dorks get laid
so one of the things is no what you do
is if you see four girls this is what I
read I met the guy once you see four you
see four girls at a bar I hate it
already but go ahead you see the one
that you don't like that you do like
don't pay attention or her you don't pay
attention or you do condescend like
remarks yeah you go you see something
like you call that hair like what are we
in the 80s and then you start like you
be hitting on the ugly one that one yeah
is going to like you I somehow do don't
think that would work yeah it do weird
it works but it's it's some losers ship
because you like got like lower girl
self-esteem so that she'll like you
exactly it sucks I I hate the idea of it
but and initially when I
was you see yeah it is what it is if it
works it works it works it works it work
now that when I was talking crazy [__]
it wasn't like oh this is how I'm going
to get them it was literally just
because it was like well I got nothing
to lose if they don't [__] with me it's
[__] you if you don't [__] with me it's
[__] you that's the way I go so whereas
a lot of people I think in my situation
are just like well I'll just keep on
being nice and hopefully I'll bump into
them at like moon tower and I'll win
them over at the at the bar later then
night I'm like n if you don't [__] with
me it's [__] you yeah and we kept making
you know dopee [__] if you're shitty
with women hey there's a lot of dudes
that are shitty with women dude yeah
it's I'm not saying it's okay but we all
know there's a lot of dudes that are
shitty with women and there's a lot of
women that are down to [__] shitty dudes
let's keep it real you know what I'm
saying like there's a lot there's a lot
of girls that hanging out the ComEd
store really just trying to suck dicks
yeah that's a true thing that happens
you've seen him there I'm sure I I was
with a woman once and I and right she
she lived at my house for so I I rolled
up at The Comedy Store uhhuh
right there's what don't say her I'm not
going to say her name yeah and she's
just standing there in the parking lot
just a just just a regular white woman
yeah she's she's she's beautiful a
beautiful a beautiful white woman okay
what shape you're making yeah understand
a whole lot is more nine Cur yeah yeah
yeah she was wobbly you know what I mean
okay she's bigger big no no no no she's
normal so now it's this yeah yeah yeah
yeah I [__] it up what's the shape of
her body try try again with your hand
I'll be real I'll be real okay if you
want to be real her shape was like
this okay she's a hot chick she's a hot
chick hot chick she's a hot she's a
peace why do we I don't know I don't
know you're wild you're wild I'm wild
you're wild okay she's a PE I get I get
out of my car total peace yeah and she
comes up to me and this you you know
that this is like you know I mean I
should have like you know I mean like
alerts in my head right yeah but she
just went you know I mean you're cute
which is like already like come on what
the [__] and she's like I'm a fan of
your comedy you I mean y now I'm half
hard you are y half yep right not full
right y she goes I live here a different
city okay I drove here you mentioned the
city before yeah yeah earlier where you
I'm from Bakersfield Baro no she was
from bar oh she's from bville yeah Baro
has a great Del Taco do not knock Baro
yeah yeah wait wait wait wait I'm
sorry that specific Del taco is amazing
Andrew if you're going to do anything in
bar though if you happen to drive from
you're to Vegas and you stop in barcel
do not get ad Del Taco I will be so
disappointed in you can I tell you
something yeah I know what [__] Del
Taco you're talking about right you're
Baro is on the way to Vegas yes and
there is one town yes yes and there's
[__] Del Taco that is right off of
that Highway that you take to
Vegas and you ate there and I've never
eaten
there no but there's a uh there there's
a gas station that's next to that Del
Taco there's a few things there they
have they also have a Taco Bell there's
a Panda Express there's a Chevron
there's it's a big it's a small maybe
I'm not thinking about that Del Taco but
I'm thinking we let go of the [__]
Del Taco no we let go it's just so weird
to be like oh like to say a fast food
place which is like the entire brand is
making the food the same in every place
yeah to be like this one not in varo I
think the Baro one if I'm not I I don't
think I'm wrong on this might be the
original one ah okay yeah okay okay fair
enough but anyway go back to the story
so there's this there's this girl she's
from B Baker right and she goes I um
drove here I don't want to drive home
can I spend the night at your house oh
right okay and I was single at the time
okay and she was a beautiful woman so I
go okay all right so we sit there and we
watched um MTV let's go yeah right at
the mood like [__] aiz yeah yeah dude
that's how I know aiz was a ner nerd
when he put on
Seinfeld and then she that dork right
let's set the
mood is that what the girl said yeah she
said Seinfeld these pretzels are making
me thirsty [__] dork come on buddy
put on mission impossible so she so she
um you know she we're watching MTV and
then she pulls out a titty mhm you know
what I mean which is like you know it's
a sign singular one titty what was the
shirt like like a loose t-shirt and up
top that's Savage and it was like you
know I remember the nipple yeah pinkish
right and with you know I never sucked a
titty before I made out with a girl
before okay right it's like kind of
eating like the dessert before the meal
almost completely reasonable right but I
went for the dessert you have to cuz the
titties out she she opened it up wait
she stretched the color of the T-shirt
no it was like a loose like you know
this is a responsible woman right here
I'm sorry you don't do that this is I
understand everything right now like not
like I hadn't before but like the level
of responsibility that while you're
talking about this girl that you may
have had sex with she's going not what a
[__] for [__] you the first night
she's going who stretches the
collar like that girl is trash like
you're stretching your shirt like next
level I'm also offended by you saying I
may have had sex with her I don't know
I'm I'm telling you I did well now
you're telling me but I'm not going to
put that on you okay but I'm telling you
that I did okay cuz I'm a closer that's
what you oh all right were you laying
up so a titty was out right and went for
the titty sucked it right and then so
she started living at my house no yeah
for like a week oh yeah yeah she
wouldn't leave okay you know I mean and
we were just on the kitchen table all
kinds of stuff right yeah it was a great
and then um but the 7eventh day in um we
were at a restaurant okay and I had a
comic call me and go um yo dude that
girl you're hanging out with uhoh don't
bring her to the club uhoh and I go why
he goes because I'm bringing my
girlfriend oh right and I'm like why
does that matter why would that M why
would that matter right yeah bro we're
all [__] that girl so she was getting
rinsed yes interesting yes just Rin
we're at dinner and I I get off the
phone with my friend right and I turn to
her oh God and go um are you getting
rined are you being rinsed by other
Comics right and she goes are you
getting your fanny rinsed right and I go
um can you tell me who right she goes
you have a pen and a piece of paper no
yeah right she started like you know
what I mean it was like the Dead Sea
Scrolls it was just like you know what I
mean she had a unravel unravel she's
unraveling yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was like you know what I mean the list
open micers I mean you mean New York
Comics Midwest Comics you know what I
mean open micers it was crazy the most
insulting I know and I looked at her and
I go we can't do this yeah and you know
what the most insulting thing is
what so a couple years later oh
God to me and he mentions her name goes
do you know so and so I go yeah and I go
did you he goes did you and I go yeah
and then 2 days later he comes back up
to me and he goes yeah I I'm I'm seeing
her I asked her she never did with it
with
you she did she admitted to the Dead Sea
Scrolls right 5,000 names right but she
[__] left she she
denied she [__] denied it wow that's
disrespect we've had some bad times
there though in Belleview oh we sure
have oh yeah we were watching this movie
there oh I had to bring this up again
but we're watching this movie there and
some so you know when we watch scary
movie like when you watch a scary movie
right in in a theater you ever watch a
scary movie in a theater sure do you
ever scream mm you're a man cuz you're a
man I don't know it's just yeah I don't
let it out yeah I do I'm a vocal kind of
a guy how do you keep it in yeah like
how do you express fear or being like J
I don't I try not to express anythingit
keep it all in when you are you quiet oh
yeah will you close your mouth Well I
this voice is not conducive getting a
vagina wet like if you were had if you
had to say something what would you say
ah God come on yeah take it [__] yeah
you like it [__] yeah yeah yeah my girl
likes a real real insult oh she likes
insults yeah but then if I do it in the
kitchen she hates it all right right
it's weird it's weird yeah so anyway
we're in the theater and I scream we're
watching this movie hereditary do you
see it oh no I too scared what I saw
midr or mid same
same yeah so I couldn't watch the other
one oh wow well you should see it's very
good it's too heavy man that stuff bugs
me I don't want to be scared what do you
watch Three Amigos yeah I love Three
Amigos that's a great okay all right
yeah yeah I screamed and then the lady
and the couple in front of us goes can
you keep it down you know what I mean if
you're going to scream like that watch
it at home what she watch at home watch
it at home and I'm like this is part of
it yeah and we we almost got a fist
fight
after we waited until the they knew that
we were sitting in back of them and the
the movie ended and the credits rolled
down and everyone would leave left the
theater except us four right so her and
I just sat there and we stared stared at
the back of their heads and as soon as
the lights came out oh my God he turned
around and like cussed out [__] what
yeah but then we went he drew first
blood which is was a mistake Art of
War wait he did or you did no they did
oh they cussed us out angry well they
just assume don't make a [__] angry yeah
yeah you know that old saying
sure that old proverb that you get from
the forun I know Shane
Gillis man yeah yeah you know it's
interesting to because you know um I
just have to say this you know um how do
I say this sing it sister I think if I
was gay yeah which I'm
not
Jeremy um that I would find you to be
cute oh thanks you're cute
[Music]
too I just I just want to let that sink
in yeah I mean but just let the silence
speak for itself there was a character
on Thundercats that you look like I love
Thundercats yeah the I think you're
nervous under cuz it was intimate what
we're doing and you to talk over it I
had to get out of it so I I want you to
look at me right now I know don't get
out of it I'm going to try to slide back
in say tell me that I'm cute again right
look at my eyes you don't talk for 30
seconds hold on I can't find your eyes
and you count okay all right all
right very funny very funny but no
you're cute thank you your feet aren't
even hitting the ground you're talk Ador
you're talking right see you're cute
again and say anything ready but lock
eyes but lock eyes lock eyes ready say
you're cute say
it
sorry so here's what my point though is
is that thank
you my point is is that because I've
seen your stand up and stuff and there
is um you know you're cute you know you
can skate you know you're from New
Orleans you know you but you have this
low self-esteem sure
yeah yeah and where does that come from
I assume it's parental upbringing
something like that bed weather braces
early hair black neighborhood a lot of
it's a big gumbo of of bad news yeah
yeah yeah and I think that probably did
it you think so I guess I don't know
because when you met me I salivating I
was foaming but when I you met me I
wasn't this [__] fat but you were
tubby you're a tubby not a lot of
definition let me say something to you
Mark Norman all right all right I was on
the wrestling team in high school get
out of here yeah what wait come on wait
a minute you you were wrestling with
your
sexuality wow no I was on the team
[__] can we pull that up there I don't
have it there is there online put Bobby
Lee picture cuz there's a picture of him
with his varsity pick like in the
wrestling stand oh you should have
fought Ben asran I think I beat him that
Jake Paul thing same yeah yeah yeah do
you see that fight yeah that was wild
him in a singlet wa look how hot you
were that's me and that's my brother my
brother and I were both wrestlers oh my
God look at the definition of my arms
bro pretty good yeah pretty solid I mean
I was 16 yeah yeah yeah so anyone else
hard I mean this could have got my life
could have gone a complete oh yeah what
happened stand
up you mean you find comedy and you go
oh I don't have to do that here here
yeah and it's also like I think guys
work on their body I know some they they
they say it's about my health right and
they say it's about you know I just want
to stay fit right it's all about getting
women you think I think deep down inside
I think down inside they want to look
good for the opposite sex right oh when
you get naked yeah or that's why people
work out as a you know I think you know
and they get nice cars because of that
and it's all that's the B I know a
couple juice heads that uh really are
just love sucking their own dick and
have no desire to look good for women
they're just they like have yeah I've
seen Maybe
selfies and [__] yeah but for me it's
like you know when
you're 54 MH right and you're
Korean go on right and you're you're
living in America and you're you know
you're you're trudging you know along in
your life and you grew up with San Diego
is white very white very blonde you know
you know what I'm saying yeah so it's
like in my early 20s you know you kind
you I still have all the SE ual organs
that you have Mark sure I mean funny
what so funny you almost forgot his name
I know because I was getting emotional
it's because I knew I know his [__]
name all right all right but it's like
you know keep going
Billy you're doing great